Hunter Hunter is Back featuring all of
your favorite characters Blood Man punch
woman and of course bird cuffs seriously
the balls the balls on Togashi to come
back so many years later and just
pretend like nothing ever happened I
love it I really do respect that Togashi
decided to Simply continue the story
he'd begun and for a mangaka to create a
series return chapter featuring none of
his main or look let's be honest even
secondary cast and have it be this good
is phenomenal this chapter had no right
to be this good and for people who've
been heavily invested in the succession
War this chapter was a shot of narrative
adrenaline this is what we've been
waiting for however I feel like a lot of
people will have read this chapter
having completely forgotten what
happened during the song and look don't
worry I got you so here's the tldr of
what's happening and why we should care
we are currently at the beginnings of a
conflict between the three main mafia
families of kakin this was started by a
dude named luini from the Haley family
who killed some members of the Chara
family and almost framed the Phantom
troop however the Phantom troop being
the wonderful gents they are what worked
out their differences and they're now in
a sort of shaky alliance with the Chara
family they have a common goal to kill
the leader of the Hill Lee family Morena
and also to find hisoka meanwhile the
guys we focus on in this chapter are
none of those people I just mentioned
these are actually high-ranking members
of the third family the Gu Family who
have been tasked with the same Mission
killing Mirana and finding hisoka why
are they looking for hisoka you ask
that's a good question that's because
both achara and the ziyu family bosses
value stability above all else and they
see the Phantom troop as a threat to
that so either they want to find and
kill hisoka first before the Phantom
troop causes too much chaos or
alternatively they want to find and
assist hisoka in ridding the ship of the
Phantom troop their intentions with
hisoka are left a bit deliberately vague
but that's why all of the nen fighting
is happening in this chapter and the man
of the hour is Henry veganduffno stupid
name but you know what they all have
weird names it is so hard to put this
into words but Henry is like he's he's
just one of those characters that I've
been waiting very patiently to become
invested in because he had potential
like he has those crazy guys that tell
me he is either going to be insanely
cool or just brutally killed potentially
even both and we got to see his
nanability in action in the previous
chapter actually but it was nothing
compared to the Fantastic display in
391. the ability itself is called All
Creatures Great and Small biohazard and
it's one of those known abilities that
would be like almost useless in the
wrong hands and I tell you this I will
never look at pigeons the same way again
which is what I love about this power as
of yet Henry doesn't go with the obvious
when it comes to animals or even objects
for that matter because I feel like most
people with disability would jump
instantly to the Lions the tigers and
bears and all of the other apex predator
crap but this dude is slaughtering
people primarily via the power of
pigeons everything Henry chooses to use
his ability on seems while it seems so
mundane like oh let's combine handcuffs
with pigeons or cameras with domestic
house cats neither the animal nor the
object is in any way impressive on its
own but the way Henry uses this
mundanity to give himself a supreme
tactical Advantage is the sort of thing
that nen combat is all about I mean just
think about it from the opponent's
perspective you see a dude with some
pigeons which by the way this led to
probably one of the most badass lines in
all of Hunter Hunter go ahead call your
backup as you can see I have plenty of
pigeons I mean God Henry is just so
unexpectedly cool but look unless you're
a hyper Vigilant and Veteran the whole
pigeon thing it's probably going to
underwhelm you and lead to lowering your
guard if only slightly which is what
makes all the difference the guy scenery
was up against by the way they are not
an end veterans not anywhere near it
they are morenas nen newbies who have
only become users in war like the last
week so they've had abilities fast
tracked them and I still think they're a
bit drunk on novelty Powers although one
of them actually got the better of Henry
which actually proves what I was saying
about how even slightly letting down
your guard makes all the difference
Henry definitely got a little complacent
in this fight even as an experienced nen
user you cannot underestimate any
opponent because you can never fully
predict their abilities Henry thought
that he'd run because the Cuffs were on
and he paid the price for that which was
quite a substantial wound and I think it
shows that Henry whilst very very clever
is also vulnerable and when it comes to
anyone on hisoka's level he's he's
probably gone in an instant I was
actually quite interested by the ability
showcased by alcondra whose name I'm
just not even going to try to pronounce
because conjuration of an object using
your own body is something I'm not
entirely sure we've seen before we've
seen enhancement of the body even to the
point where remotes feathers became
blades purely through the power of
enhancement but this actually shows
better than anything how inexperienced
the sky was with using Nan the problem
with Conjuring an object onto your body
is that conjuration is about as far from
enhancement on the nen ring as you can
get without being a specialist so yeah
look he can turn his body into weapons
cool but he doesn't have the aptitude to
enhance his own body after that which
means it's kind of like the equivalent
of say like Conjuring an aluminum foil
shaped ax onto your hands and just going
he doesn't have the oomph to use it
properly it's a really half-assed
measure and just an inherently flawed
idea the key would be much better off
Conjuring objects on their own with
their own unique properties and maybe
splashing in some transmutation Nation
but there's no one there to teach him
that so his life basically amounts as a
learning exercise for others back to
Henry though look I don't think this
will happen but I would love to get some
insight into his background because he
clearly has Origins with animals and
nature and is able to wield its peaceful
docile and fearsome aspects in equal
measure it may also be worth considering
that pigeons are a more advanced faint
make your opponents think mate he is so
deadly with like the stupid animals and
then the lion gets whipped out out of
nowhere unexpected I hope we continue
down the simple path though because I
want to see what other Mayhem Henry can
cause with these just ridiculously
common creatures to Jojo fans I'm sure
this ability will also provide a bit of
a flashback to a certain gold experience
because it is quite similar to that
stance function and that probably
shouldn't come as a surprise because a
lot of the succession more abilities are
clearly JoJo's stand inspired something
interesting though I did praise Togashi
for continuing exactly where he left off
but it is worth considering that the
outline for this chapter was probably
already completed several years ago when
the Hiatus began as well as maybe two or
three more that's just how the manga Pro
process works at any moment most mangaka
have stories outlined for the next three
to four chapters so we might not yet be
in a situation where we are seeing
post-time scriptogashi in action so it
makes me very keen to see just how the
story will shift once we wrap up this
Clash minioc let's talk more generally
about Henry's mission of killing Miranda
she has recently been flagged as a much
more important character than we may
have previously suspected because she is
the sole figure on the cover of vol 37
which is interesting because Togashi
doesn't really put smaller characters on
volume covers especially not as the sole
focus with that said we're in a bit of a
Race Against Time here because there
will come a point where killing Mirana
is absolutely useless in case you're
unaware her ability is called contagion
which allows her to infect 22 people
giving them the power to participate in
a fun nen game where every person they
kill is worth one level and every kill
of a nen user is worth 10 levels but but
if you kill a kakin prince that is worth
a whopping 50 levels and once someone
reaches level 100 they become a member
zero which means that they get to infect
another 22 people so it's like an end
plague and very similar to the Chimera
and problem in the same way that the
queen dying didn't help once the king
was born Marana dying at this point is
theoretically useless because she's
already done her part actually that
might not be true Morena herself is a
level 45 so maybe if she reaches level
100 then she gets to infect another 22
people but the bigger problem now is
stopping the existing 22 people from
each being able to infect 22 more people
I guess we've solved one of them now and
that's one down just 21 more people but
this chapter also reminded me about one
of the things I love most about Hunter
Hunter which is that we get Henry's
inner thought process regarding Morena
he's speculating that oh maybe she's
trying to start up another Revolution
maybe this is a training camp basically
he's giving her a lot more credit than
he should because we as readers know
that Miranda just wants to burn it all
and there's no really sophisticated
plans beyond that and this was actually
one of the things that frustrated me
most about Hunter Hunter going through
it the first time the fact that Togashi
dedicates so so much time to the inner
speculation of characters that we know
for a fact is flat out narratively wrong
I think many authors would see this as
something of a waste of time because
it's not necessarily giving new
information to the audience in fact in
some very poorly written cases it might
make the characters look dumb because
they don't know what the audience knows
but that's also what makes Hunter Hunter
feel like a living breathing world the
fact that every character has their own
inner train of logic just chewing away
it's almost like we as readers are
involved in more of like a voyeuristic
reality show I also love that scene with
people taking selfies on their way to
the Dark Continent and I might be wrong
about this but I think this is the first
time we've ever really begun to explore
the third tier of the Blackwell one
which according to the depiction in this
chapter appears to be like the upper
middle class tier tier 2 is role of the
hyper wealthy and celebrities are then
of course tier one is where the king is
Queen's plural and the princes reside
Henry does also flag the fourth Prince's
relationship with the haoli fam he is
theoretically their benefactor but we
also know that Miranda has basically
abandoned seradnik and has usurped the
family for her own purposes but with sir
adnik currently being occupied by that
teeny tiny succession more there's not a
whole lot he can do about it right now
all right to the other two now zakuro
and Lynch the explanation of zakura's
ability was pretty cool he's a natural
manipulator and if I understand this
correctly he's constructing a legion of
miniature nenbeasts through the standard
combination of emission and manipulation
which if you're unaware is basically the
magical recipe for nenbeasts and I
imagine that this would actually be
quite difficult and very Aura intensive
to do in any other circumstance hence
why you need that added restriction of
using zakura's own blood and even then
he can only do it for like 30 to 40
minutes Lynch meanwhile is namita who
basically has a truth punch ability she
asks people questions and she punches
them with the emitted Aura forcing them
to give truthful responses which could
lead to quite the dramatic situation you
know punching some are asking are you
hisoka and then just this ominous answer
yes followed by like a shot of Lynch's
seventh head because hisoka is brutal
now but these are the two who have been
tasked with finding hisoka I mean the
Chara family are also looking for him on
the lower tiers but hisoka is unlikely
to be there it also like like to point
out that illumi is currently on tier 3
and the theory that illumius hisoker in
Disguise is still going pretty strong in
my mind but as much as I love Henry I
really don't have as much faith in his
underlings are growing Lynch and maybe
that's because I know that they right
now have the more difficult task of
trying to find the super powered clown
murderer who is far more dangerous than
any of the mafia nen users and you know
what he's probably far more dangerous
than any of the successional princes as
well so it's hard not to feel just a
little bit of fear for their Futures
also Togashi did a one-page color page I
said Paige twice but this chapter
featuring gone and yusuke from you
Hakusho which I think may have given
readers the even more wrong impression
of the chapter on multiple fronts again
if you were reading this from just
hearing the news that oh Hunter Hunter
is back and I imagine this was a very
weird experience for you however more so
than gone and yusuke I'm interested by
the background creature because it seems
to be wearing the sea down on top of its
head almost like a nenbeast
manifestation of the seed on itself with
big old Chompers ready to consume
several courses of cartoon princes
before [ __ ] out 30 or so years of
Kingdom Prosperity I'm just glad that
Hunter Hunter is back though I know it's
not gonna last long but look these next
few months are going to be glorious and
I know that because despite the fact
that this chapter has no main characters
in it whatsoever it was still a
fantastic read and I cannot wait for
more but I will because I have to and
luckily this time it won't be a long
wait